Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for a very special episode of the Monday morning
podcast.
Our little offshoot,
a little spinoff like back in the day,
you know when somebody would guest star like Mork on happy days and they would
just be like,
who is that fucking guy?
The studio audience loved him.
We should give that person their own show.
Well,
you know what dreams really do happen in Hollywood and they also have in the
podcasting world because our own Nia,
our own beautiful,
lovely near,
we're doing a Nia log because because you're,
you're fucking podcast room is still gutted because we're waiting for the
mortgage company.
Right.
Because they took our money away because they didn't trust that we were going to
get the money from the insurance and then the mortgage company had to take the
money.
That's right.
Because they want to make sure that we were actually going to put into the house
so we can go down to the fucking and distributing ihops cock suckers.
Yeah.
All right,
well this is,
but it's been a good night night.
Nia.
I know you don't watch sports,
but the,
uh,
I,
I mentioned,
I mentioned on the podcast that the Celtics have fucking hot.
We're old.
We're an old ass team.
Last year,
what the Celtics did last year,
taking the heat to seven games was,
was incredible,
man.
I was just like,
these guys are winning like games.
They should not be winning.
Just fucking desire.
All right,
and now this year I'm like,
all right,
we lost a old twinkle toes there,
whatever the fuck his name is.
I'm not a big basketball guy.
We will,
we lost them down to Miami.
I'm like,
now we're really fucking old and that we get Jason Terry and replacement and
then fucking Rondo goes down.
I'm like,
we're finished.
We're going to get pounded by the Knicks and the next go up three games to none.
You have to win four out of seven.
So if you went four in a row,
you get swept and we get swept.
That means one,
one thing.
Your team is a bunch of bitches.
It's not true,
but that's what people say.
So like right now there's a lot of like Laker fans right now that are probably
feeling that.
And I feel sorry for that.
You know,
people would probably say that about their team and it's not true.
Do you feel sorry for them?
They're probably being called a bunch of swept bitches and,
and a lot of love was shown to Boston over the last few weeks.
So I'm going to show a little love to the Laker fans and say Ya,
you know I feel bad for you.
Okay.
And if I could somehow get you a coupon and go get you some botox.
Oh yes.
So patronized so nobody could see your brow.
Furrowing I would fucking do it.
I do it in a second.
So the Celtics win one game,
cause we're the fucking Celtics and you don't sweep us love when somebody talks
shit after the victory.
Who doesn't even watched the sport?
Now I'm standing up now.
It's supposed to be the near log when I got to get this shit and now we'd
fucking beat the Knicks again.
It's three games to two.
We beat him in the fucking allegedly Mecca,
whatever the fuck that means.
I remember it's a gathering place for people to come and beat the fucking Knicks
beat to Nick's.
We beat him again.
Now it's two to three fucking boss.
Your big forehead is sweaty.
Yes.
Cause I was just,
cause I just worked out because I just worked out sweat again.
I work out.
I Dunno.
I don't think,
I just don't think we've got enough to beat those guys.
But like just the fact that,
you know,
we're making them nervous because we fucking came back against those God Damn
Yankees.
Oh yes we did.
They were up three games to none.
That's when we first met.
Remember that came back four games straight.
We do that to that base baseball team and then the basketball team's fucking
tremendous.
All right.
This is a Neil Ogg.
Everybody,
you never fucking know it.
That's three minutes a shit talking all the lunch bunch of women right now
going,
oh my God,
just shut up and let her talk,
including me.
Oh Gee.
Ooh.
Wasn't that a little too shea fucking tone cooling leave.
Hmm.
All right,
let's get right down to it and I'll let ya on Monday's podcast,
I was talking about the,
uh,
which is really a fucking old story at this point,
maybe is the first,
uh,
basketball player,
athlete,
whatever,
to come out and say that,
that,
that he was gay and actually Martina Navratilova and said,
ah,
just to God,
they a minute.
Got their minute.
I came out in the 80s when they could yell homophobic stuff.
Me Add a while.
They sold Cheerios,
been a couple others,
mostly women.
There was a woman on the Mba who came out as well,
but this women don't play in the NBA.
This is she grabbing towels for the men that play in that league.
The WNBL.
Oh,
that doesn't count up.
Really.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
A lame name,
one team and the WNB.
Okay.
Name.
That doesn't mean that that's not valid.
Just because I can't name it Colorado cleavage.
They've won the first six years.
Um,
that's not true.
No,
but it just,
cause I can name that doesn't mean anything,
but I'm not as Memphis anyway.
Straters the Memphis mess.
I can't name as the,
there's the La sparks,
there's the,
uh,
professional athletes who have come out.
So he's not necessarily the first,
but he's the first because it's the NBA.
So what are you saying?
What do you,
what do you think about it?
Should he have shitty of kept his,
uh,
his little lungs?
Dillydallying Deli's I'm trying to say it without cursing.
No,
I think it's great that he came out.
It's a,
it's a big deal for,
for the sports world now,
especially at the NBA and the NFL will follow suit.
Maybe not right away,
but soon.
I have always said I wanted it to be the most manly,
the dude that all the homophobic guys,
not all.
And I never even sports bars homophobe but there's a lot of the ones who already
have his Jersey and I want them to be wearing it.
Who,
who would that be though?
What the most manliest do?
Doing the NFL or NFL or NBA?
I was talking NFL.
Well,
who's the most manliest aren't they all pretty manly?
if I had my choice,
if I,
I've always been a fan of beards.
Um,
no,
Tom Brady's not considered the most manliest guy.
Everybody calls him a pretty boy.
Who would it be?
I just want to one of those sexual,
just one of those fucking,
you know what I mean?
One of those fucking guys,
and I'm just trying to get to the joke here.
[inaudible] going to be standing there in the fucking sports that Jersey on
right now.
They're going to look like his girlfriend was there wearing his jersey.
Why would they look like his girl little boyfriend?
You know what I mean?
Because in high school when you date all the ladies when they were banging the
quarterback,
whoever was bang and it got,
got to walk around wearing his jacket and they pull the sleeves up like an
eighties comic.
And that's what I was trying to fucking get to.
But this isn't about me,
although it has been for fucking seven minutes.
Here's my thing.
I don't think it's any big deal,
but what,
what,
what about the showers?
What about,
should she be allowed to go into the showers?
I said I
allowed to,
if he didn't try to make any sort of moves,
he's not going to.
Now that such as like,
that's such a kneejerk fucking homophobic,
ridiculous reaction.
Oh God.
Now that I know that you're gay,
you're going to be looking at me.
You're going to want to try to rape me.
It's like if I didn't try to fucking,
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking no,
it isn't nonsense.
It is.
It's like this ridiculous reaction feeling like I'm not saying that he can't
fucking shot.
First of all,
why don't you,
all I did was I asked the fucking question and all you fucking jerk offs
immediately.
Just homophobic.
He should have to pay a cover charge.
Oh Jesus.
A Cup of charge.
All those shredded dudes,
fucking abs and all that.
Dick's down to the floor.
This is what the fuck is until we get to look at that for free.
That'd be like,
don't be like me fucking,
I get to shower like I come out and just say that what?
Just what if I came out and said I was gay?
Can I then go fucking shower with a bunch of Victoria's secret fucking that
doesn't make sense.
You wouldn't have before,
so yeah.
No,
I'm just saying you don't get to shower with the thing you want to fuck without
paying.
You got to take somebody to a dinner.
Oh,
it's how you're getting,
I'm fucking around for Christ.
Sake of fun.
You know what?
Something's going to chop that up and I'm going to have to make an apology,
but I don't have to.
Who am I going apologize to fucking fruit loops.com.
Who the hell do I have on this item in that I didn't mean that.
You know what it was?
I was trying not to say stamps.com Jesus.
I'm going to have to erase this fucking podcast.
You know it is fit.
Told you to watch that.
I told it to watch that go fruit loops is my go to product.
I already said Cheerios.
I always go with cereal.
You don't think so?
It's different now.
It's different.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
I've said a long time ago how I feel about the gays in the community that they
live in,
which is what I think's a REIA there,
I think.
I think years from now they're going to look back on this and see that.
See the way gays were treated and they can look at it the same way as like when
you used to stone somebody cause they were a witch.
I'm just having fun with this shit.
Give me a break.
You don't think he's fucking psyched standing next to Colby who like God,
he's the best basketball player standing next to me.
You are ridiculous.
Why would he look?
He's been looking.
All right.
Well here's the thing.
All right,
well what about,
okay,
now we're getting somewhere.
So He's been looking hypothetically,
he's been looking,
but no,
no,
no.
Let me back into this corner for a second so we have a little fun.
Why am I here?
So He's been looking right now.
Let me ask you this.
If I'm standing around,
all right,
bunch of naked women and I'd been looking,
I'm called the creep.
Get out of this locker room.
You creepy.
Creepy.
It's like,
what you think I'm going to rape you?
I'm just looking at you.
A little Bush over there.
That's all I'm doing.
Smelly.
How come I can't do that?
It's not the same.
Why can't I go shower with the lady?
How come I can't do that?
This is,
this is reverse.
Uh,
whatever it is.
If he gets to shower with the fellas,
probably alone now he knows how people feel.
Fuck.
Probably he'll probably purposefully separate himself because he doesn't want
people to feel uncomfortable.
No,
I think,
I think what?
I think what he did was great.
I'm just having a fun,
I'm just having fun out there who are actually taking this shit seriously.
You know?
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
You know?
I got to be honest with you.
I thought he did.
It was great.
That's great.
It took a lot of bulls.
It did.
It's like a lot of fucking balls to do to do what he did.
Especially when it seems like that's a sport where,
oh,
he's,
because he's got all those guys,
you know,
random tweets and other kinds of bullshit,
it's such a,
you know,
masculine.
All the,
the world of sports anyway,
when it comes to men's sports is seen as a very masculine,
you gotta be a certain kind of guy,
a tough guy,
a strong guy,
a guy that's not afraid of pain.
Who's going to go out there and just,
you know,
and Chris,
when Chris Bosh cried after they lost the championship,
he got a ton of shit for it.
He collapsed to the ground and cried it out when they want,
when they lost.
Oh,
and they lost.
Well,
yeah,
it's fucking the bad.
A lot into it right now.
He just said,
well,
you're a lot of emotion into it.
Why wouldn't you?
But yeah,
but because you cry,
you're seen as weak because we're guys,
what you supposed to do is take that ball of sadness and stick it next,
add it to the big ball of sadness in your chest.
One day you're out there with the hedge clippers.
When you're like 55 and he just dropped and that's it.
You guys cry it out,
right?
I heard you keep your memories and your chest.
So I know it's a wonderful thing that he did,
but it's one of those things where now these done,
it's amazing.
I need to read that sports illustrated article.
That's when he officially came out because it supposedly as a great article.
But I guess what people feel,
even though it's amazing,
and I don't think anyone is discounting him from it unless they're,
you know,
feel weird about an NBA player coming out is that while it's amazing and great,
they feel like it's going to take a quote unquote bigger star to really affect.
I thought that was annoying.
I thought that that was annoying.
That's what they stole.
That guy's fucking thunder.
Well,
he had the fucking balls.
You know what come out and I and absolutely.
But the thing is,
it's kind of like with AIDS,
right?
So everyone had a certain feeling about,
well this is,
I'm gonna make this parallel because it makes sense when when people were
talking about aids in the eighties and nineties there was a certain conception
of who got aids.
It was a gay man who was sleeping around or whatever it is.
But when Maddie Johnson a huge respected,
revered,
loved athlete,
straight,
not in Boston,
it doesn't matter when he came out that for a lot of people,
maybe not normalize it,
but put a face on it was sort of like,
wow,
this is a kind of person who could be susceptible.
So maybe it's not something outside of me and I don't know about this.
And that's those people that do those things that somebody like me,
a straight person who has a family,
but Bob who was careless,
this is,
you'll get aids.
And that's what changed for a lot of people that,
that face of AIDS.
So it wasn't just gay guys sneaking around in the alley.
It became trust street guy.
Well yeah,
but it also became a straight,
very masculine,
like I said,
revered hero to a lot of people.
And so it's sort of like,
oh wow,
we're all vulnerable if we're not careful.
Careful.
So what people are saying is,
even though I,
I get it,
I'm listening to you.
So even though Jason Collins coming out is a huge thing and no one should
discount it,
there are people who think,
wow,
that's amazing.
They need a straight guy.
It was a huge [inaudible] that would maybe affect,
if it was a Colby and Colby blind.
I have his fucking moment.
It was his moment.
Absolutely had the balls to do it and then fucking the twinkle toes.net has to
come out and be like,
well actually we'll cut.
That was good,
but we want somebody more high profile this fucking asshole.
But that's not what they're saying.
They're not taking it away from him,
but they're just,
but no,
but that's selfish fucking agenda that they want something more.
No,
they're looking at it as well,
this is wonderful.
I wonder though,
if this is really going to have the impacts on the sports,
can I get a word in for that?
And something like a magic Johnson would have.
That's,
that's,
that's all they're sending.
No one's taking anything away from them.
They just don't know if that's going to erase quote unquote homophobia from the
sports world because it's not somebody like a,
a shack or a,
you know,
I haven't gotten that,
whatever.
Now let me that,
let's say you win an Oscar.
Okay?
You win an Oscar and then some women's group comes up,
right as the handing you that fucking trophy,
they go,
you know,
this is all well and good,
but now do you feel like you got your moment?
Well,
no,
I wouldn't feel that.
Thank you.
Defense rest.
But I'm not,
I'm saying it was let's,
it's a valid perspective,
but it's not taking,
it's not taking anything away from him,
but I mean,
I,
can I give the guy a week?
Can he have a week?
You're saying because anytime anyone makes a big announcement like this,
there's the people who feel that he's a hero and then there's the naysayers.
He's not a person to them.
He has this thing.
He's this thing to throw against the wall to continue.
Fuck,
give the guy his fucking weak.
He had the balls to come out.
This is his fucking week and he ought to be hit,
but you know,
he finally gets the shit off his chest.
He can finally just,
you know,
relax,
build,
fuck.
Fucking is not have to worry about somebody saying something and whatever the
fuck it is that you have to go through that horrific fucking life that you
shouldn't have to go through.
She ought to be able to just be who the fuck you are and to just after he
fucking,
the second he comes out,
they had these douchebags be like,
you know,
that's all well and good.
He should have taken his big fucking hand and mushed their faces back behind the
curtain for a second.
Anything bad by it.
I think they're just,
they're being very realistic about the world that we live in and the reality of
it is,
while you've got somebody who's done a very brave,
awesome thing,
sometimes it takes a bigger celebrity or whatever to making away from him.
Can he have this fucking week is all I'm saying?
No,
I know.
I get what you're saying,
but they also have a valid point.
I mean,
do you think Jason Collins coming out is really going to affect the way we'll
see driving me up the fucking wall right now?
Not Listening to me.
No,
because I said like five minutes ago,
I said,
if you won an Oscar and as you wanted some woman's group when I'm,
you know,
this is all well and good,
but blah,
blah,
Blah and stole your thunder,
you would be pissed.
And you,
and you believe that women should continue to be advanced,
but can you have your fucking moment?
I think that they robbed the guy didn't happen,
but I think by them saying shit like that,
I think it's a,
it's a,
it's,
what's the word?
Not Crass.
It's no,
I understand what you're saying,
but not a classy fucking thing,
but give the guy a couple of days,
this man Jason Collins coming out at the time he was coming out at this point in
his career with his standing in the NBA.
Do you think that it's going to seriously impact the way people see gaze and
professional sports like basketball or football,
et cetera?
Do you realize?
I gotta be honest with you like,
Oh wow,
I can't speak.
I can't speak for other people.
But that's,
but that's the question.
Can I,
can I answer the question is,
here's the thing.
You said all that shit about Magic Johnson and this put a face on it and blah,
blah,
blah.
That is the,
that is the legend now that it's happened the same way.
Like when Nirvana's nevermind came out,
everybody's like,
you just knew the second you heard it.
There was a change in the air.
That's all fucking,
that's the legend.
And I've always said that.
I heard it,
I didn't get it.
And I was waiting for the next skid row album.
I didn't get,
I didn't get fucking Nevada.
I,
I wasn't old.
I was,
I was starting to become old.
Like my,
like my generation was being passed on.
Like I was not grunge,
I was fucking metal.
So I didn't get them.
And how great the musicians they were until they did their unplugged.
And I was like,
wow,
these guys,
and they did all these covers and shit.
And then I worked my way back and as I worked my way back to the whole thing was
over when Kurt killed himself.
But that whole Magic Johnson thing was,
first thing people said was,
he's gay,
he's gay.
And all this shit came out.
Oh look at him kissing Isaiah and the cheek before the finals.
All right there.
There you go.
That up.
They said that shit.
And then when they,
if people who,
like
we're saying no,
no,
magic is still straight than what they just said.
Well as well,
I'm not Magic Johnson,
I'm not fucking six women at a time.
I'm fine.
So,
and I think that's what most people do because it's scary that you're looking at
something that could kill you and your thinking in the back of your head.
All these skanks you banged without a condom,
you know,
laying there in bed going,
this could have me too.
There's,
that takes a certain level of fucking maturity that most people don't have.
Especially when you're younger,
you think the,
the appreciation for Jason Collins,
even though he's getting so many accolades,
the g the real appreciation is not going to come until later.
No,
no,
no.
What I was saying is what that whatever that fucking website was,
I thought it was uncool that they said this is great,
but you know,
this is all well and good,
but I think that I thought they'll run in moment.
I think it's fucking phenomenal debt.
He did it and I hope more people do it and everybody just fucking relaxes and
it's no big deal.
Right.
Well I think that's,
that's absolutely 100% true,
but I think they were just sort of has any Lisbon funny that sounds like a
fucking town meeting.
There's this being realistic about what the impact to be and no one can really
know.
And so I don't know,
a month,
a year,
three years from now,
how come they won't interview anybody who doesn't give a fuck?
Like me,
I could give a fee gift.
I could give a flying hair that's not in fuck about what you do.
Off The court unless,
unless,
unless you're killing people.
No,
I don't care.
I don't care how now you don't care.
No,
no.
I'd like to read.
I don't care
what we already discussed it then we got so,
okay,
but let's actually bring some sort of comedy to the,
okay.
You got really mad at me last night
before we went to bed.
I'm not going to say who I was looking at either.
All right.
Yeah.
That of protection.
This is what happened to me.
He is fucking on her side trying to go to sleep and I got the laptop and I start
doing the IMD thing and I'm looking and I'm looking and I'm looking.
Yeah,
she doesn't believe this.
So I find,
I find some style it right.
And it says that,
you know,
she did a spread in playboy,
so I'm like,
Oh really?
Wow.
I want to see a naked.
So I go to click on images.
I swear to God,
I'm on Google images and some,
the second I clicked on one of the naked pictures,
this other window came up with somebody talking who?
I don't remember what they were saying,
but you immediately assumed that I was watching porn.
Cause when you click on a porn,
that window that opens up behind the window,
those girls on the Webcams,
they pop up in their leg.
Hey Daddy.
No they don't.
They usually papa.
I
said first time you hear it,
like where's that voice coming from that somebody hacked into my computer and
they're mocking the porn that I'm watching.
And then you go,
it's just,
oh there's some fucking housewives sitting there with a pickle.
Um,
a couple of kids running around the background.
It's tough economy.
God.
So she immediately assumed that I was watching porno and I was like,
I wasn't.
And I literally backtracked through the fucking thing.
I backtraced it and I showed you what I was watching and then he called you a
fucking scumbag fucking scumbag piece of shit.
And I never,
it is.
It's like you're watching porn too.
If you know that that happens,
but that right then,
but I'm not watching it fucking line next to in bed you dirt bag,
which you worry if know if he even to look at naked ladies on a computer naked
in bed.
Ladies.
Well lying in bed.
So whether you're watching porn or not,
I still stand by those harsh words.
Artistic.
They don't show the clam there.
They just show a nice little La,
you know?
Yeah.
And I heard that pop up in that breathy little,
oh my God,
this and that and hey and I knew what you were doing and I fucking screamed at
you.
You fucking deserve my next to me it'd be looking at porno while in bed with
your future wife.
You fucking scumbag.
I don't take any of it back.
You're a dirt bag and you deserve
to be yelled at in life and on the pot.
Money is,
we got such a great mattress here that I think I could actually rub one out
without you noticing.
That's nice.
That's what they should do.
That's what they should do in that commercial.
You know that commercial,
they have the wine on one side and the guys jumping up and down.
They should have some guy with his hand inside his fucking jam jams fucking
shark and like this and looking at the camera.
Given the thumbs up,
you just say you just see the bedspread fucking,
yeah.
So yeah,
so that's what you think I was doing.
That's that is what you were and maybe you weren't looking at actual
pornography.
Pornography.
It was a nude.
It was naked pictures of another fucking woman.
You got caught and I screamed at you and you fucking deserve it.
All right.
You called me a lot of harsh words.
Well you deserved it to do it while you're lying in bed next to me.
What kind of man are you taking him to that level.
It might be the quarter of the podcast.
I just wanted to look at this naked girl and then,
then what happens?
I was taking that found out I was on IMD being and this actress,
what's her photos?
I MGB and what I am.
DB had a link to her fucking naked videos and then some mother fucking popups
that come up.
You were caught and it's a move for us and you're trying to make it funny or all
the guys listen to right now.
Here's the move in this moment.
If I want to look at a naked broad on my goddamn computer,
all right,
I'm going to do it.
You absolutely can,
but it's all right with what you're sharing are fucking would be marital bed.
I'm not going to stand for that.
I'm going to call you names.
I'm going to shame you and that's how it is possible.
A me half my childhood.
Your shame.
That's why we're talking about it right now.
No,
no.
I was trying to bring up something fucking funny.
Sacrificing me.
Fucking look.
Give me so that's how it is.
Yes.
I looked at a fucking naked actress.
All right,
there you go.
And I enjoyed it and I'll do it again.
No you didn't because I screamed at you and it's the toy away from from you.
There was a lot of shame.
I was so like soap.
You know what it was.
I wasn't prepared and then that lady's voice.
I have.
I got it.
Yeah,
and then you fucking rolled over and you would just fucking in my grill and I
was sitting there just stuttering trying to shut it off.
I couldn't find the mute button.
It's unreal.
Yeah.
Well
you don't do that.
That's rude.
I didn't set out to do it.
See Internet.
Eventually you're going to end up at a fucking naked to do it.
You lied here with the specific intent of looking at a woman naked on the
internet.
Yes.
You did.
Said,
oh,
I want to see those pictures.
And you clicked on it.
Oh,
that's not what I saw.
What you did start in the middle of story.
It didn't expect was there to be a pop up to appeal to the kind of perverts over
the head that you are and
I can't look at one fucking broad.
Let me tell you.
Absolutely can look at you on the road.
I'm going to take one minute and I'm going to put it over your face.
Me In bed and be looking at some naked women and get found out like that.
Yeah.
You're going to get called on it.
What do you spend them on?
The snuggle up snake.
Ooh,
let's look at it together.
Fuck you.
Okay.
Oh,
there might be one of the greatest,
fuck you was out of a head.
Fuck.
Oh,
that was beautiful.
I was thinking you guys got a bit when it comes to fucking lay in somebody out.
All right.
Yeah.
I have to tell you this.
I didn't go.
I didn't take over my computer and be like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I'm going to look at this naked girl while you're laying next to me.
I went on I N D B and I'm such a weak,
pathetic person that within three seconds I ended up on that,
but that's not,
I'm like one of those guys who's fucking did the crime.
This is second degree.
This isn't premeditated.
I didn't fucking walk in.
They're like,
I'm going to look at this girl.
Okay.
I walked in.
They saw the gumballs sitting there.
Stomach was growling.
I said,
fuck it.
I'm grabbing them and I got caught.
So yes,
I did rob the fucking store,
but I wasn't sitting at home going,
you know what I'm going to do today?
All right,
this and just throw a naked woman in there and you have the fucking explanation
we're looking at.
You knew who she was.
You knew that she posed naked.
You knew because you know who this person is.
All right.
Without going any further.
So for you to sit here and try to act like,
oh my gosh,
I was just investigating someone's life acting history.
Timberlake showed us fucking wiener on the Goddamn Internet.
You'd look at it.
What does that has to do with anything that we're talking about right now?
Because you know what?
You were right.
You can I finish?
Can I finish?
Sort of.
You were right up until three minutes ago.
Just tried to throw me off base,
but you're not going to do that playboy because I'm smarter than you.
All right.
And that was not be quoting dialogue from a bad cop show.
Yeah,
I didn't do that.
Playboy.
Why don't you put your little,
your little gumball fucking siren on top of your nonexisting car.
Listen to me.
You will.
Right up until three minutes ago.
What's what's is now.
You know what you're doing now.
You're Hammond it up.
Oh,
your hand man is out.
You know what usually happens on the podcast should have ended with fuck you.
Can you please do it again?
Not You.
Alright,
there you go.
People.
There's podcasts.
That's the meat.
A log.
That's the NIA lie.
Listen,
I'm sorry that I looked at a,
a talented actress naked.
You know what do you want me to do?
Will you shut up and stop outing the person you already fucking left like 90
clues.
What is wrong with you?
Be Mad at me.
Don't be mad at her.
I'm not mad at her.
Well then quit fucking doing that.
All right,
see he keep it again.
Keep it at me.
No,
I'm not.
This is about you and you know what?
This is what happens.
You know what?
This.
This is what happens every night around eight o'clock and nine o'clock and then
she fucking drives me out of the house and I go out and do stand up.
Okay.
Yes I am.
And you can watch all your stupid.
Was it?
What was that fucking show you were watching
the show about the swimmer who doesn't get anything but swimming?
What would Ryan lucky deal.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
He's,
he's hamming it up.
Yes.
I don't know that he is.
He's traveled the fuck at world.
He's won gold medals now near now.
No,
he's traveled the world and met with diplomats.
He traveled the world and jumped from pool.
He has met with diplomats when he went and fucking gold medal,
homestead and get the key to the city.
This guys cut ribbons.
Okay.
And he's open suits guys often zoos.
You're not that.
He's not that dumb.
I don't know about that.
That's hot and that's really all that matters.
Okay.
And now,
now do I get upset?
Then I'm sitting on a couch and you're sitting there looking at fucking,
oh,
that's what you said the other night.
You see at this look on your face and I'm like,
you're not enjoying the show.
And you're like,
no,
I'm looking at those abs.
And if I was lying that see you looking at naked pictures or whatever of Ryan
Lacosse,
then you would absolutely have something to say about it.
So wait a minute,
that's not what happened as much.
I show.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
So the bed bedroom is not cool fucking bedroom.
It's where we,
I know what you're doing.
A bedroom,
it's a sacred space.
He believe this shit guys
got a swell guy like me would have to put up with this shit.
Can we not have the bedroom at least.
Okay.
But if,
but if I did it in the living room,
if I did it in the living room,
that would have been okay.
If I'm not in the bed with you,
yeah,
you're out.
No,
no,
no.
There's no,
there's no bed in the living room.
If I'm in the fucking living room,
I can look at a picture of a naked woman on the computer.
I just want to,
no problem.
I just want,
okay.
And if I hit on the thing and all of a sudden it grows,
I have,
I mean,
right there
you're not,
you're not gonna have a problem with them not letting them know.
But while lying in bed next to me,
that's a problem.
I can live with that.
So we're so we're absolutely.
So I paused.
I didn't know that that was the rule.
And once again,
Nia,
I was just looking at a fucking picture.
All right,
I'm a fucking guy.
She's a naked woman.
What am I supposed to do?
It's
one click away.
How do I resist?
As if you had no choice.
I really don't.
The way I'm wired,
I don't.
All right.
Oh,
please,
I don't accept that.
Oh,
fuck you.
And you want to Nia.
What if there was no,
I don't necessarily that Nia,
what if there was a store you could just walk into and it's a bunch of free
shoes in a store right now.
Wait a minute.
It's a fucking metaphor.
It doesn't matter.
We're not talking about metaphors.
We're talking about what actually happened.
I'm talking about how you're wired versus how I'm wired.
Okay,
you're aren't,
but you like stuff.
The guys,
you're in the shit.
You like hats.
You like fucking shoes.
If a free hat or a free pair of shoes was a click away,
you'd fucking do that right in front of me in the bed.
You would,
and then I heard some night here at somebody [inaudible] who is he to win?
The fucking hat is not the same as what you were doing.
It's just not the end.
When you started to apologize for it and now you're trying to batch,
because I was trying to fucking apologize.
You keep coming at me like a goddamned mere cat.
I don't try to keep coming at you.
You should keep trying to like excuse yourself or what you did and you know that
it's wrong.
You know what?
I know you think that you're doing some amazing shit here where you just not
back it down.
Okay?
First of all,
what are you going to do to me?
Nini?
Huh?
What are you gonna do?
How are you going to body slam me?
I'm bigger than you.
I already said,
I have pushed you right off the fucking bed worn or whatever it is that you do.
I have no problem with that.
But if you're lying in bed next to me.
And I said okay.
And I said fucking settled.
I said,
Holly won it.
And I said okay.
So then we have nothing left to discuss.
End of podcasts.
Why do women always take the ball and go home?
How old are you there?
I'm on that point,
but it's over and end of game I won.
I'm going home.
All right.
Whatever.
That was your podcast for this fucking
look.
I mean that's self satisfied.
Laugh.
All right.
That's the,
that's the uh,
Neil log this week.
Cause you,
cause you can see why I don't have her on that much anymore.
I know I'm never on anymore cause you're busy,
busy doing stuff.
What are you doing?
Not Doing Shit chastising you.
See Ya.